اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من جنوب لبنان اهلا
بكم كتائب القسام تعلن الاجهاز على قوه
اسرائيليه من مسافه صفر في كمين ببن سهيله
شرق خانيونس والاشتباك مع قوتين اخريين
وتقول ان مقاوميها دمروا عددا من الاليات
الاسرائيليه في حين قال المتحدث العسكري
الاسرائيلي ان الجيش يعمل على تحسين اداء
قواته عشرات الشهداء في قصف اسرائيلي على
خان يونس المنطقه الوسطى في قطاع غزه يرفع
عدد الشهداء خلال 24 ساعه الى اكثر من 120
والمكتب الاعلامي الحكومي يكشف ان عدد
الشهداء والمفقودين
29700 بينهم 100 الا طفل وزراء اسرائيليون
يتوقعون ان مجلس الحرب لن يدوم طويلا وها
اريتس تنقل عن اعضاء في المجلس الوزاري
المصغر ان الجيش لم يحقق حتى الان ايا من
اهداف الحرب في حين دع وزير الدفاع لعدم
استغلال الجيش لتحقيق مكاسب سياسيه حزب
الله يقول انه استهدف اهم قاعده للمراقبه
الجويه شمال اسرائيل ب 62 صاروخا كرد اولي
على اغتيال صالح العاروري في وقت دوت
صفارات الانذار في 944 بلده في الجليل
الاعلى ومن جهته اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
استهدافه مواقع لحزب الله وشنه هجمات في
جنوب لبنان
[موسيقى]
لقاء